okay hi everyone
we have another episode of my uh
q a about science and technology for
kids and others and i think we have a
few
saved up questions here i noticed one
here
the question was when will we run out of
scientific innovations
is there a limit to technology you know
there's a famous story
that's told i think from about 1900
about the person who was responsible for
um the patent office
which is the the place and this was one
in the us
where people who've made new inventions
register their inventions
to make it clear that the inventions are
theirs so to speak
anyway this person said basically
in about 1900 uh kind of ah everything
useful that could be invented has been
invented
you know we've got millions of patents
that have been issued about
inventions of all kinds of things you
know
everything that is useful that could be
invented has been invented
well that was a bit weird in 1900 you
know there were the wright brothers with
their plane coming in a few years there
were cars that were just starting to
exist
there was all kind of innovation in
bicycles there was refrigerators
oh and you know then coming another
probably 40 years later where computers
and everything computers have brought us
so that was kind of a a short-sighted
thing to say in 1900 was everything that
can be invented has been invented
and i think there's a question will we
ever be able to say
everything useful that can be invented
has been invented
and i'm pretty sure the answer is no i'm
pretty sure
that for reasons that are actually kind
of
reasons almost mathematical reasons
there will never be a limit
to what can be invented so we have to
think a little bit more carefully about
what does it mean
to have an invention what it probably
means is we're going to take
something in the universe something that
has
it can be made out of physical
components you know
some metal that we mined somewhere some
some
gas that we can construct in in whatever
we're going to take something made out
of physical components that we find in
the physical universe and we're going to
turn that into something that we
find useful so there's sort of two
constraints there
what can you find in the physical
universe what can you make things in the
physical universe do
and what things do we find useful
now you know you could imagine if you
let a very boring life
oh what to me seems like a very boring
life and all you did all day
was you just sat in one room and you uh
maybe you you grew some food and you did
this and you did that
and nothing much else happened
one could imagine that well you wouldn't
really need you know
many other things that um
uh uh to change i i'm reminded many
years ago i was
um at a dinner at
um this is kind of a silly story but but
um i was at a a dinner at
um at oxford university at a college in
oxford university
and the colleges in oxford university
some of them are very old the first ones
were
were came into existence i think in the
1200s so
800 years ago now and one of the people
who was there was an old chap who worked
in
some subject that uh as you know the
history of things that happened
thousands of years ago and was in the
kind of oh
nothing really ever changes in this
world you know the only thing that's um
that's really uh significant from modern
technology in his world
is that you know the dinners that they
have the thing that
um uh you can kind of slide a tray
across the table
uh with a with a thing made of you know
teflon or whatever it is some some low
friction thing
and that for him uh was sort of the only
important feature of of modern times as
far as he was concerned
for most people there's a lot more use
of kind of uh the innovations that get
made in the world but
to some extent the innovations that are
worth making are
features of what we think is worth doing
so to speak
so then there's the question so then you
have to sort of start asking this
question
what's possible in the physical world
what do we care about
so there are probably limits in the
physical world to things we can do
for example if we want to send
a signal somewhere there's probably a
limit we probably can't
send a signal copy can't make anything
go
faster than the speed of light probably
light is the thing that goes the fastest
in our universe probably we're not sure
about that but probably that's true
um and so if we say well the thing we
really really want to do
is make something which travels faster
than light sorry
the universe as the universe exists just
doesn't make that possible for us
but um uh if we start um
even when it comes to something like
that even though we can't
send a signal faster than light there
are all kinds of weird effects there's a
thing called quantum teleportation which
doesn't really quite send a signal but
it kind of sends something else
at a certain speed and a lot of the time
when people say oh there's a
physical limitation that makes such and
such a thing impossible
there will turn out to be some maybe not
a direct
way that you can solve the problem but
something where you're kind of
you're kind of finding a way to work
around the problem i mean in
um a famous example of this about also
sending signals
was uh years ago i remember people
saying if you want to
communicate between computers the
fastest you'll possibly be able to
communicate
is a thousand bits per second a thousand
so if you were sending um uh you know
text or something a single
a single character in text is usually
encoded in about eight bits
so that means that term let's see if i
can do my arithmetic properly
that the fastest you be able to send
things is maybe 120
characters per second would be the
fastest you could send
um any kind of computer data information
okay so if that was the case we'd be out
of luck sending movies
to um uh you know computer to computer
and so on because that's a vastly larger
number of
bits per second and so on but so and
people had all these arguments oh if you
have these
wires and these radio signals and things
you'll never be able to send things
faster than this or that
for practical so physical reasons but it
turned out
that there were all kinds of things
where people said oh the the rate at
which there will be errors will be too
high
but then people figured out how to make
error correcting codes
oh there'll be bursts of of noise and so
on
then people figured out how to sort of
get around those and in the end
you can send data of millions of bits
per second routinely done
um through exactly the same sort of
physical ingredients but the exact
details of how those bits are sent and
what rules you have about whether a bit
that is sent will always arrive before a
bit that's sent after it and all those
kinds of things
those rules have been relaxed a bit
because it turns out for the things we
actually want to do
those don't matter much so anyway the
the
this question of uh uh you know what can
you invent
what constraints are there in the
physical world um
that limit inventions i think
the thing that actually has been a
consequence of my project
about fundamental physics recently is
we've realized the incredibly close
connection
between sort of what happens in the
physical world
and what happens in computers what
happens when you're computing answers to
things
turns out to be essentially the same as
what's happening in the physical world
when the physical world
has things happen in it and also thing
that's much more even much more recent
is a realization that what happens in
well what's usually called meta
mathematics a kind of generalized view
of mathematics
is also the same and it turns out
that in these more abstract theories in
computation and meta mathematics
there is there are fundamental results
that basically say
there will be new things you can figure
out there will be no limit
like in mathematics you might say just
like you could say
all the inventions that have been made
in of devices and so on
you know might have already been made
well they haven't you might say in
mathematics
all the mathematical results that are
worth
establishing have already been
established but we can kind of show
in a very theoretical way in a very very
formal way a very sort of a
definite way that um that that can can
never be the case there's no limit
there's an infinite frontier
there are always more mathematical
results that you can derive
um that you won't have derived before so
i think i think we can fairly say that
that um
that there isn't a limit and and you
know when when you
um uh the kind of way to think about
this
is let's see if there's a way to
describe this
a lot of these questions come down to
questions well given these rules for how
a system works
is there a way to set the system up so
that when the system is following those
rules
it can do the following kind of thing
okay where the following kind of thing
is something you want from it you know
you want it to generate
some sequence of numbers you want it to
do this or that of yellow
and and you might say well gosh you know
given that thing i want well how would i
know
if i could how would i know if i can get
it well one way to know you can get it
is just to say here's a way to use those
rules to get what i want
okay you're done you you've proved that
you can make that invention so to speak
okay how would you prove you can't make
that invention
well you'd have to say there is no way
of setting up these rules and setting
things up so that
you can get this thing i want but if you
just start
imagine how you would show that one
thing you could do is you say well i'll
just try all the possibilities and i'll
just
show that nothing works it's like you
try all the possible inventions
to prove that it's not possible to make
a such and such device
um but that the the thing that goes
wrong with that idea
is that partly because of a thing i call
computational irreducibility which is
sort of a fundamental fact that i've
been a lot involved in
in working on um you you you pretty much
are stuck
just having to try all these
possibilities and if you can't say
well uh it has to be the case that
within the first
trillion things i try something will
show up or it's never going to show up
if you don't know how long you'll have
to go how many things you'll have to try
how many different things you'll have to
try before you find a thing that works
then then you'll never be able to say
for sure oh there's nothing that works
and that's kind of the i mean the formal
version of this
is related to this thing called girdles
theorem in mathematics
it's related to halting problem in
theory of computation and various other
kinds of things but
the basic end result is you never know
you can't do something
because you end up having to say
uh well i could try all these
possibilities but there's no limit to
how many possibilities i'd have to try
before i find something that works and
given that
i i can't say for sure that it doesn't
work because i would have had to try an
infinite number of possibilities to be
able to say that
let's see um
it's a question here
there's a question from sarah here is it
possible to build a place
without gravity well
so the gravity that we're most familiar
with
is you drop something on the earth and
it falls to the ground
that's the the the general rule of
gravity
is that objects that have mass
attract other objects so for example the
earth because there's a big mass
will attract other objects through the
force of gravity
and so things that you
drop will tend to move towards the earth
what does it mean to move
towards the earth in the end partly
because the earth is a sphere
it means that things will tend to move
towards the center of the earth
now obviously when they hit the ground
they don't go all the way to the center
of the earth
but they're always moving in a direction
that goes towards the center
of the earth actually that's not quite
true it turns out that
the mass always produces gravity
but if you look in different places on
the earth there's
you might think everything will always
fall down towards the center of the
earth
but actually because there are things
like mountains for example which
have mass if you drop something sort of
to the side of a mountain
you can end up with a situation where
the thing is is turned a tiny bit
towards the mountain
it's actually falling a little bit
towards the mountain as well as falling
towards the center of the earth
actually that story is a little bit
trickier because of the way that
mountains
float on the mantle of the earth um and
so there's some there's some slight
trickiness to that but basically
what is it i think it's about um one
in a million roughly i think is the um
uh you're going sort of to the side
about one millionth as much as you're
going down when something
falls on the earth but in a first
approximation
gravity on the earth uh works the way it
does because the earth has a mass
and so anything gets attracted by
gravity towards the earth and towards
the center of the earth
now one of the things that can happen is
if you are um okay so so
how do you be in a place without gravity
well
as you go further away from the thing
that has mass
the amount of gravitational force that
it exerts goes down
it goes down roughly like uh the inverse
square
so one over the square of the distance
and it's roughly this i mean
so that means if you're twice as far
away the force of gravity is one quarter
as much
if you're three times as far away it's
one one one-ninth as much
and and roughly the way you can think of
it is the um
if you think about a a sphere for
example and it has a bunch of mass
and um you just imagine that from that
sphere
there are these little things going out
in all directions that are trying to
pull things in with gravity
and actually there are real particles
they're called gravitons
that probably you can think of gravity
as more or less being like this whole
stream of gravitons is coming out from
an object
and going outwards and every time and a
graviton can kind of pull on anything
to get that thing to go closer to an
object okay so here's a
here's the thing to think about if you
have a certain number of gravitons
and um they are uh every graviton is
going to exert a certain force on
something
but the question is as you go further
away from the object how many gravitons
will actually reach you as you go
further away from the object
so at the when you're right close to the
object let's say there were
a million gravitons that came out in a
tiny tiny fraction of a second
from that object that we're going to
produce a force on on things around it
okay the million gravitons are going out
in all directions
okay if you are a certain distance away
what's and and you have a certain size
what's the chance that
in that moment a graviton let's say it's
going in a straight line
will reach you well that depends on
let's say they're a million gravitons
they're all going out it's like a big
hedgehog like
thing everything's just going out in a
straight line from the center
the question is um why uh how many
uh if you are out if you're a certain
distance away
how many of these gravitons will reach
you so let's say that you were
right on the surface you were something
where
one of these gravitons you were a
certain size
and on average every zeptosecond or
something
tiny fraction of a second one graviton
would would reach you
okay now let's say let's say that that
was the case for
for the for the on the surface of the
earth which is a certain size
now you go further away what you realize
is the further away you are
the number of gravitons that go through
a certain area
will go down as the distance away goes
up
and actually if you know the um
uh the math of this if you have a sphere
of radius
r the the area of the surface of the
sphere
is 4 pi r squared so that means that
that as you go a distance r away
the any given size the total area
of of that you have to that these
gravitons have to go through
goes up like r squared but if you are of
a fixed size
the number of gravitons that will sort
of go through you goes down like one
over r squared
and that's basically why the force of
gravity decreases
like the inverse square of the distance
it's just because you're having these
essentially gravitons just streaming out
but there just aren't there are fewer
and fewer of them that will reach you
um if you're a certain fixed size as the
distance you are away goes up
okay so that means if you're far enough
away
from every massive object in the
universe
there won't be much gravity um so
if you were out between galaxies
things like that there won't be much
gravity
you know the main gravity you'll feel is
gravity that's pulling you towards that
galaxy
now if we really get tricky about it
it's
a little bit more complicated because
there is there may be
a a sort of thing like gravity that is
associated just with a vacuum
and that's a complicated issue of
physics um
and uh there's this thing called dark
energy that might
exist in the universe that's sort of a
little bit like that
but in a first approximation if you're
far away from any known sort of massive
objects
then you won't feel much gravity um so
that's one way to be in a place without
gravity
another thing another way of appearing
to be in a place without gravity
is if you're like in orbit around the
earth
um if you're uh so as i say
when when well let me explain this
this way let's say you're an elevator
and you drop something in an elevator
the elevator's stationary
okay you drop something it'll just fall
to the ground just like it ordinarily
would but let's say you're in the
unfortunate position that the elevator
is in free fall
that the elevator is no longer acting as
a
elevator with all its counterweights and
all that kind of thing the elevator is
just dropping
right it's just falling maybe maybe
you're doing some bungee jumping
insanity or something like that and
you're just falling or you're skydiving
or something
those things don't quite work that way
because of air resistance but in a first
approximation if you were just
just falling as fast as you could
towards the earth and you dropped
something as you're falling
well then you won't see that thing
fall to the ground because in a sense
the ground in your elevator is falling
as well
so relative to sort of the ground the
thing you drop
won't seem to fall at all it will seem
to be weightless
and the same thing happens if you're in
orbit like in the international space
station
it's the same situation the
international space station is always
falling towards the earth but because
it's going a certain speed
sideways as well by the time it would
fall and go splat on the earth
it's actually gone far enough sideways
that instead of just going splat on the
earth it just
keeps going around the outside of the
earth that's what happens when things
are in orbit
and in that situation things will appear
to be weightless
because in a sense the ground is falling
as much as anything would fall
okay so another question might be
so so i said that that um you know
anything with mass
attracts things gravitationally and the
same is true even with
with satellites it's a very very small
effect but if you have two if you had
two international space stations
they would have a small force of gravity
that will tend to attract them together
it's a very small force
um and uh uh but but um
that that's uh would eventually do that
but um so one of the things that this
kind of assumes is
that everything has a positive mass
because
the force of gravity is as
is associated with the mass of an object
if something has a positive mass
it's going to attract everything if it
had a negative mass well then it would
repel
things that's the way it would work but
one of the things that is seems to be
true about gravity is there are no
negative mass
objects in the universe and um
when you have electric charge for
example there are both positive charge
objects
and negative charge objects like a
proton has positive charge and electron
has negative charge
but for gravity for reasons that well i
think we now know from our fundamental
theory of physics but
hasn't really been known before in
gravity
you only have positive mass you that no
negative mass exists
now people wondered uh for example when
you have antimatter
the kind of uh the opposite charge
version of particles
so an antiproton which instead of having
charged plus one has charged minus one
um people wondered until quite recently
until maybe 30 years ago
they wondered would antimatter fall down
towards the earth like it has positive
mass
or would it fall up because it has
negative mass well
turns out antimatter falls down so
antimatter
like mata has positive mass and so far
as we can tell
everything has positive mass actually as
i say in our theory of physics we kind
of understand now
why that would be the case um but
actually there's a little bit of a weird
exception
which has already been thought about in
in the physics of the last 25 years or
so
which is this idea of dark energy and
here's roughly how this works
so the question is when you think
there's nothing there in the universe
when you think you have a perfect vacuum
no no particles there's no
you know no atoms of hydrogen there's
just nothing there's some
when you think there's nothing there um
is it really the case
that the the that the vacuum
has zero mass and that's been a tricky
thing in physics because
in the official theories of physics that
have existed for 100 years
one those theories particularly theory
of quantum mechanics
says that the vacuum should actually
have
a non-zero mass in fact it should have a
huge mass
in fact in the vacuum there should be
these little funny quantum processes
happening
so-called zero-point energy and the
zero-point energy should be absolutely
huge
and it should be so huge that sort of
everything the universe should attract
itself and the universe should curl
itself
up into a little ball and it's been
quite unclear i mean for example
our our theory kind of explains why that
isn't the case
but it's been difficult to see that but
one of the other things that can happen
is independent of that independent of
the zero-point energy issue
there's also the question of is there
some uh
kind of kind of thing that we don't
yet have a way to detect that will
act as if it's a negative mass thing
that's just spread throughout the
universe
and one of the things that's observed in
the universe is it seems that the
universe which is expanding
is accelerating just a little bit in its
expansion
and one way that that acceleration could
happen is if there was negative mass
stuff in the universe
and so that is usually called dark
energy
and so one of the possible theories is
that there's something we can't detect
it it doesn't seem to interact much with
with anything that we can measure or
anything like that but maybe there's a
little bit of negative mass spread
throughout the universe
um that actually has an interpretation
in our models of
physics um that is uh basically the
the this when i talk about um all the
zero-point energy and all this activity
in the vacuum and so on
in our models of physics it's that
activity that actually creates
space in physics that actually creates
the the possibility of saying there are
two distinct points there's something
here
and you have to move move move to get to
something here
that those things are not just all
squashed together there's a notion
of going going a distance within the
universe
and the thing that creates that notion
of going a distance that
the the thing that creates something
like space
is in fact precisely this all of this uh
activity that has been called zero point
energy
it's a little bit different than that
but but um it's it's that kind of idea
and in that setup one of the weird
things that can happen
is most of the universe is just full of
space doing its thing
and and being being sort of knitted
together by all these little processes
that happen
and by the way when we look at in our
theory we're not
completely sure about this but um uh
in um uh there's a question of
the things that we are sensitive to the
things that sort of happen in space
the atoms and so on that exist in space
the protons the electrons all those
kinds of things that exist
um how how important are those
relative to the processes that just sort
of knit together the structure of space
at least in the current theory that we
have uh for every
uh sort of thing that is creating like
an electron or something
the amount of stuff that is just
associated with maintaining the
structure of space
is let's see a trillion trillion
trillion trillion trillion trillion
trillion trillion trillion
trillion times larger so a lot larger so
the vast majority of the activity in the
universe
is just maintaining the structure of
space and everything that we see that
sort of happens in space
is in a sense a tiny effect but one of
the weird things that can happen is
maybe those effects can actually cause
some of that activity
that creates space to be a little less
than it normally is
and if that happens you end up with
negative mass
but so that's the that's a long answer
to this question about can there be a
place without gravity
um the answer is uh in the usual theory
it's like if you're away away from all
these masses but you can imagine a
different
much weirder situation where you have
positive mass things and you have
negative mass things
you're kind of balancing those to end up
with a zero mass situation
where you don't have gravity but but
right now we don't know how to do that
if we were trying to make an
anti-gravity machine or something then
we would need that but
it's not clear that's possible oh there
was a question here about his negative
mass possible so i think i tried to
answer that
um
let's see there's a question here
a question from brian here do you think
there's anything between the known
particles
um and
other elementary particles that's a
little bit of a complicated question so
so you know remember atoms
as we know them are sort of made of
protons and neutrons in the nucleus and
electrons
and protons and neutrons are made of
quarks and gluons
and if we kind of drill down drill down
drill down what's inside what's inside
what inside what
the things where we don't know anything
inside them are electrons
quarks photons particles of light
um there are there are a few particles
where as far as current physics is
concerned we don't know anything about
what's inside them
and they seem to be of zero size now
in our theory of physics nothing is of
zero size
because space is made of these kind of
discrete atoms of space
and so just like if you say if you have
some water for example you say i want
a really really tiny amount of water
you're going to
you're going to have a very careful
you're going you're carefully measuring
out water
and you want a really really really tiny
amount of water okay you have i say i
have a like a milliliter i have a micro
liter i have a
nano liter this is all yeah it's fine
i've got a little dropper i can have
that
that amount of water but if you try and
get a really really really tiny amount
of water
you get stuck because at some point
you're down to having only a few
molecules
of water and at some point you say i've
just got one molecule
if i want even less water than one
molecule how do i do that
i can't have only part of a molecule so
to speak
and in our theory the same is true in
space if you want to have
really too small a distance you
eventually get stuck there are no
spaces discrete on that scale you just
can't go down
to a smaller scale and so
when we look at things like particles
like electrons the idea that an electron
would be of zero size is not plausible
in our models
in fact in our models an electron is uh
probably
uh well one one estimate is it's um i
mean in
in scientific notation will be 10 to the
minus 80th meters
roughly um that's uh
oh let's see if i can do it a trillion
trillion trillion trillion trillion
trillionth or something of a meter
so very tiny uh by comparison if if
in our theory an electron is 10 to the
minus 81 let's say meters across
by comparison a proton is 10 to the
minus 15 meters across so
a proton is huge compared to an electron
so for example let's see if we compare
us
to the size of the universe for example
um so let's say let me just uh do this
calculation times my six
yeah so the the difference in scale
between
us and the size of the whole universe
is larger sorry is smaller than the
difference in scale in our models
between an electron and a proton
so in other words if you were to sort of
line us up end to end to go across the
whole universe it would take about 10 to
the 26 people
um if you were to line up electrons to
go all the way across a proton
it would take let's see if i can do my
math properly
um 10 to the
60 uh
10 to the sixth 10 to the
65 uh 10 to the 66
electrons you would have to line up so
immensely more electrons would have to
be lined up
one against the other to fill you know
to go across a proton
then we humans let's say a meter tall
give or take would have to be lined up
to go across the whole universe so
so the electron is very very tiny but
not of zero size
okay so the question then is
even below the size of an electron in in
our models
how much further is there to go well in
our model there's about
a billion trillion uh
the compared to the elementary length
the shortest possible length
the electron would still be a billion
trillion
of those elementary lengths so there's a
lot of room to make something even
smaller than or
smaller than an electron and so whether
such things exist we don't know
um is it is it possible in our models
that they exist absolutely
could those things exist and be floating
around the universe quite possibly
there's this thing called dark matter
that exists in the universe or seems to
exist in the universe
and it's possible that that's what it is
is these particles that are very light
compared to electrons very small
compared to electrons
i should explain what dark matter is so
so i talked about gravity
and uh you know when we have a galaxy
for example
our galaxy has a hundred billion stars
in it
and our galaxy is slowly turning around
i think it turns around oh my gosh
how long does it take uh 100 million
years maybe
for the galaxy to turn once on its axis
but the galaxy is a it's a big sort of
spiral shape it's roughly flat
and it's a big spiral thing that slowly
turns on its axis
actually the center of our galaxy has a
big black hole um but it's so
slowly turning around there okay so
based on the laws of gravity we can work
out how fast the outer arms of our
galaxy should be turning
based on the number of stars that we see
in our galaxy and based on the mass
that exists in those stars and we get
the wrong answer
in fact we get an answer that's wrong by
a factor of 10.
um and so it seems like there's
lots of other stuff in our galaxy that
we're not seeing and there are even
situations like where two galaxies have
have uh uh have gone through each other
um they can do that there's enough sort
of empty space
very few of stars will hit when two
galaxies collide with each other
but some will um but uh you know they're
cases like that where it seems like
something is left behind where these
galaxies collided
that is being called dark matter and
there's a question of what dark matter
is
i think it's possible that it's things
we call oligons in our theory
um it's there are many candidates for
dark matter one thing we would we know
for sure
is dark matter interacts very little
with ordinary matter
and so people are interested in you know
can you do an experiment
to find dark matter could you see
whether you can get the dark matter
to interact with this thing in this very
special way you know one of the hopes
these days is the one thing we know for
sure is dark matter has a gravitational
effect
because that's how we're noticing that
it exists is because of the gravity that
it produces
and so maybe just maybe something like
the gravitational wave detectors that we
have
something a little bit like that might
maybe possibly
be able to detect dark matter but it's
not clear
let's see uh
the question here will technology allow
for one true universal language
for deaf blind romance languages arabic
asian computer languages
eliminating the need for translation
well it's possible you asked the right
person that question
so i have for a long time been
interested in making
computational languages where we can
express in a way that computers can
understand the kinds of things we want
to talk about in language
and if you use wolfram alpha which
powers
knowledge and things like siri and alexa
and so on if you ask it questions
you say you know what's the density of
gold or something or what's the
caloric content of some kind of cookie
it what does it do it takes that natural
language in english let's say
it converts the question you're asking
into its internal computational language
which will be something like the entity
the element
entity gold uh its property density et
cetera et cetera et cetera what is the
value of that that kind of
that kind of thing it converts it into
this precise kind of symbolic
computational language
from which then the computer can go and
get the answer go and figure out the
answer compute the answer
so one of the things i've long been
interested in is making
a general language that can express
anything you want to express in a
computational way
i call that the symbolic discourse
language
um people actually you know the idea of
doing this it's an important thing
because
if you want to for example if you're
trying to explain to an ai
if you're trying to define for a
self-driving car
what should its ethical principles be
about you know when should it swerve to
avoid this thing when should it not
what should it do you have to like tell
it that in some form
that is a little bit more general than
just saying if there's this
patch of pixels in your camera then do
this you have to make some principle
about some kind of contract with it
about what it should do
and the question is how do you express
that and that's where this kind of idea
of a computational language is symbolic
discourse language
comes in as a way of expressing that
instead of writing a contract like
people do where it's written
in kind of legalese you know a variant
of english that's been made a little bit
more precise
you write it in computational language
and there's kind of a question of can
you write
everything can could i do this
conversation that we're now having
in a computational language and
would that allow one to understand that
more clearly perhaps than by expressing
it in english
well one thing that's a little bit like
that but about 400 years old
is the idea of mathematical notation i
mean i could say
let's add um you know three
two four okay
and divide by seven okay well i can say
that in words
but we know that i can write the
notation three plus
four slash seven or something um and
that idea of using that sort of precise
mathematical notation
makes it a lot easier to express things
mathematically
same kind of thing can be done
computationally i've spent uh
oh about a third of a century trying to
make sort of a computational language
that can express
lots of things computationally that's
been
very successful and is used by lots and
lots of people um
but uh the thing that um so there's a
question of
that language can express all kinds of
things but there's still things it can't
express
they're things about for example what i
want to do i want to eat a piece of
chocolate
we have a pretty good representation of
a piece of chocolate oh it's
three grams of milk chocolate of this
type
but the i want to eat part we don't have
a good way to express that
computationally
but i think it's possible to make one
and uh
if we make that then we will have a way
to sort of turn a conversation
into something that can be precisely
specified just like mathematical
notation precisely specifies
things and where if you've agreed with
somebody this is how things are going to
work and you've written this
computational contract
you both go to that instead of having to
ask somebody is this
contract does it agree with what is
going on or not
you can sort of just ask a computer and
it can decide what's true
so this is an idea that i think is a
very uh
powerful idea very important for a lot
of things about the future of the world
a lot of things about the future of sort
of telling ais in general artificial
intelligences
in general what we want them to do a lot
of things about sort of the operation of
the world and making
sort of the the transactions that go on
more efficient and all those kinds of
things and
defining things in a good way and lots
of different purposes
and resolving a bunch of issues about um
uh
you know people's preferences and how
you represent those and
all those kinds of things a lot of good
purposes um
now uh so so one question is why hasn't
anybody done this
why hasn't anybody built this kind of
symbolic discourse language
well fundamentally because it's hard i
mean i've just spent
a third of a century building the way
the distance we've got
so far and we've kind of built this
thing that's
quite unique in the world and taken that
amount of time to do
so first problem is it's hard um the
second problem is people sort of have
kind of thought it's impossible
um actually the last time people didn't
think it was impossible
was in the 1600s about 350 years ago or
something
there were a whole bunch of people who
tried to make what in those days they
called philosophical languages
languages that would express meaning but
without having a particular language's
words in them
so in those days it was like do you want
to use english do you want to use latin
no let's use a philosophical language
which can abstractly express
things without having to have specific
words they were about 350 years too
early
you couldn't really do it at that time
you didn't have computers
you didn't have a lot of other kinds of
things it didn't make as much sense then
to do it
now i think it does now what can you not
express that way
well one of the things that happens is
if you say
um you know i want to have a piece of
chocolate
um that's a statement
but you if you say i am most desirous of
acquiring a piece of chocolate
or you know i'm i i gotta have that
piece of chocolate right now
those things translated into our
symbolic language would probably be
the entity that is me you know
wants to eat you know the wants is a
thing eat as a thing piece of chocolate
in other words
the sort of the nuance the poetry of
what i might say
would be crushed out of it by having uh
by turning it into this computational
language
if what i care about is well did it
happen did it not happen
yeah it's great a great way to express
that as a computational language
if i want to express sort of the the
feelings that i had in saying it and so
on well i have to have another track to
my computational language
i have to have you know the emotion
track to my computational language which
is a perfectly reasonable thing to have
um actually perhaps even quite simple to
do but it
is showing you that you're breaking
meaning into this kind of collection of
atoms
uh that is a little different than the
whole meaning packaged together
in the way that we use it to communicate
between between us humans
so if the question is so the question
is can we ever get sort of a universal
language
where we can expect computers and ais
and humans and people
who can only see things visually and
can't hear
sounds or people who can only hear
sounds and can't
um can't see things visually could we
make something which can be
adapted to all those different purposes
absolutely yes
will it fully capture everything well
uh in almost inevitably no the only way
to fully capture everything
is to have the thing itself so to speak
and people often discuss you know if
you're making a translation
of particularly something like a piece
of poetry from one language to another
you know can you truly translate that
poem well the answer is
no you can translate certain slices of
the meaning of the poem
but can you truly translate the whole
thing inevitably no
because inevitably there will be like
for example in language one
it might be that the word for a
particular thing
is ambiguous with three other words that
are that are similar to it that mean
other things
but they aren't really what the poem was
talking about but they're kind of a
reference
by using that word to things that are
close to those other words
but in the language you're translating
into the space of meanings might be
quite different
and the word you know when you say oh i
don't know
um when you say
um oh
to say you say negatively about somebody
that person is kind of a toad
well in english you know when you refer
to toads in a in something you might be
meaning
you might be suggesting that the thing
you're referring to is is bad in some
way
but when um uh when you um
translate that into i don't know pick a
language you know french let's say
let's see i don't know toad in french
frog is grown we i think
um uh but but anyway i i have no idea
what the
what the nearby words are there but i'm
sure the meaning is not the same there
so in other words you translate the word
for toad but you won't get that same
kind of uh
ambience of meaning that you would get
in english so in that sense
it's sort of translation is in principle
impossible
but a level of translating meaning is
absolutely possible
and i think this effort to make a
symbolic discourse language which i
i hope will be my next big project once
i've quotes finished
uh figuring out the physics project
which which is ending up
having many many tentacles where it's
informing a lot of other
kinds of fields as well
all right oh boy
so many questions you guys asked so many
things
there's a question from
anders here this one i'm going to get
myself in trouble by trying to answer
but the question was
who is the leader in information
technology at the moment
and the person asking it says my guess
is china
um that may be a uh i mean all i can say
is that um uh
it's a it's a funny thing when
uh you um if you look at different
things that are being invented
what kinds of things are being invented
what in in different places
you know different countries have been
really big on you know
this is a country that makes lots of
cheese this is a country that is
has amazing woolen products and so on
different countries have different
things they tend to specialize in
and even within information technology
there are
countries that have sort of specialized
and for which
different areas are are really a better
fit
it's been a surprising thing in the
software industry
that uh most of the large software
companies and most of the sort of
most leading software companies have
been in the us
not necessarily started by people who
grew up in the us
but they've been based in the us and
back when computer
when the computer industry was young
there were many countries
like the the britain other european
countries
many countries where they were off to a
good start
you know russia another example now
they're off to a good start they had
computers they were building you know
they were building things but for some
reason the the sort of the
center of of mass of the of of the
software industry
really moved to the us and people have
different explanations for this
having to do with the the traditions of
starting
entrepreneurial companies companies
where there's a lot of risk and so on
um i think there's a variety of reasons
and maybe it gets us too far
a field to talk about them i mean i to
me
the thing that's interesting in today's
world is that i think
with even technologies that we've built
that try to automate a lot of the sort
of stack
of what you need to do computationally
there really isn't such a big advantage
for a country that has developed a large
sort of
um background in a particular area of
information technology
relative to other ones and i think it's
it's you know it's becoming much more
uh where there's a will to do it and
where there's an interest in people
really getting involved with the latest
kinds of things it's possible it's not
like
it's not like a field where there is a a
um
either uh physical resources even
factories that have been built things
like that or know-how
that is sort of uncatchable up
by by other countries even quite small
countries um and it'll be interesting to
see how that develops i'm always so
we can get a little bit of an index of
countries around the world
if we look at our software because we
make
a lot of software that's used for
research and development and so on
and the amount the the level of usage of
our software
gives a pretty good indicator of how
energetic research and development is in
a particular country
it can be a little tricky because there
are countries where people buy software
like they do mostly in the us
and so on and there are countries where
pretty much
people just steal software and so you
have to kind of correct for that
in making this estimate but but we have
pretty good index of countries around
the world
um you know and how kind of um uh
um r and d sophisticated they are
but um i'm going to get myself in in
that i think that's a different
a different topic here
um
let's see
oh boy there's a question from eduardo
here about is the relationship between
computational irreducibility
and the uncertainty principle from
quantum mechanics i
it's going to take me too much time here
to explain both of those ideas
um the the answer is not directly
in our models computational
irreducibility is associated with the
progression of time
uh the uncertainty principle in quantum
mechanics is associated with essentially
curvature
in what we call branchial space which is
the space of entangled quantum states
um so they're a little bit that they're
in order to get that second thing you
need computational irreducibility but
computational irreducibility
is pretty much the origin of time and um
that has a whole lot of other things
that it that it brings with it
um
let's see
it's a question here um
okay there's a question here from markup
is there a formal definition of number
it's an interesting question so you know
what is a number you say there are three
of something you know
three fingers whatever one question that
comes up is
are numbers necessary if we were going
to
rebuild our civilization or if we found
some you know alien intelligence would
it necessarily have numbers
if you have a spaceship do you
necessarily have to have numbers
well it's an interesting question you
know it's said
that there are you know people living in
the amazon jungle who haven't had much
contact or any contact
with them uh uh well they have to have
some for people to know about them but
um who have had very little contract
with the outside world and who have
languages
that it's claimed don't really have
words for numbers
like our language has you know one two
three four five we can count up to any
number
um we can specify you know one million
three hundred thousand blah blah blah
blah blah we can say that number in our
language
but it said that that um in these
languages
there's a a a a word for a thing on its
own
a word for a pair of things and then
there's a word for
just lots of things there's no notion of
one two
three four the notion of number that we
have
so you might say how could that possibly
work well it depends what you're doing
you know if you have uh you know let's
say you have a bunch of
um oh what is there in the
amazon jungle i don't know a bunch of um
i was gonna say sheep but i'm not
completely sure there are sheep there
let's assume there are sheep there um
let's say you have a bunch of sheep
and you uh you know you have a bunch of
sheep and
and you know that sheep is called bertie
that
sheep is called billy that sheep is
called you know
uh jemima that sheep is called whatever
right and it's like okay so
billy and jemima are off in that posture
okay
but you're not saying two sheep are off
there when do you need to count sheep
when do you need to say all these things
which we currently just have explicit
names for
are all the same kind of thing let's
lump them all together let's just count
how many of them there are
well one time you need to start needing
that is if you invent things like money
and commerce you might say i'm gonna
trade you
you know three sheep for four goats
let's say
um and uh uh then you have to start you
know having
collective ways to refer to things and
you have to start inventing numbers
but um it's i think not self-evident
that you have to invent numbers for you
know you can lead a perfectly
uh satisfied life without inventing
numbers so to speak
now you know if you look at the history
of
um of use of numbers in human
civilization
um people figured out whole numbers
integers pretty early on you know you
just make marks on a tally stick or
something like that
uh later on by the time of the
babylonians a couple of thousand
uh four thousand years ago or something
people
had figured out fractions they'd figured
out you could have one half you could
figure out one sixtieth
you could figure out you could have
these fractions and they they tended to
want to represent
numbers by oh and we have
this number and such and such a number
of sixtieths
by the way we we still use 60th because
that's where our
60 seconds in a minute 60 minutes an
hour and so on comes from
that's from the babylonians and their
use of of of of
60th fractions um now if you say well i
want 157th
okay well so you can mathematically
represent that roughly
as you know 1 60 plus something that's 1
3 600
plus whatever um but uh
there are numbers that whose
there are only certain numbers you can
easily represent
by fractions like that
so for example the square root of two
the number which when multiplied by
itself gives you two
can't be represented that way so you
know
normally if you say okay uh
you know nine is three times three
uh sixteen is four times four
uh if we wanted to say what's
five as a something times something the
something we have to put in there is the
so-called square root of 5.
let's say we want to do that for 2 the
square root of 2 is a number that's
about 1.414
multiply that up you get 2 multiply that
number by itself you get two
but if you want to write down that
number that number if you wanted to
write it down as a fraction
it would go on forever okay so
so the idea of representing numbers in
terms of fractions that was no one
4 000 years ago the idea of doing what
we do today
writing down numbers as decimals where i
could say 1.41427586 whatever
however it goes that idea
of writing things in terms of decimals
in terms of a sequence of numbers like
that a sequence of of uh
uh of you know a place value sequence
where you've got
um you know uh things that are tenth
things that are a hundred things that
are a thousandth et cetera et cetera and
having that go on forever
that idea is quite new i mean that idea
by quite new i mean it's 400 years old
but on the scale of of of understanding
of mathematics and civilization it's
quite a new
idea and this idea that there there are
you know that you can make a number
that where you can have all these digits
okay so one
one question is um between
can you make if i pick a value
can i write down a number that
corresponds that value whatever value i
pick
it's very similar to the things that i
was talking about with space
where if you pick a point in space can
can you pick any point you want
or is there a discrete kind of structure
of just where you can pick
that point but the next neighboring
point a little distance away
so with numbers there's this question of
can you pick
just an arbitrary number or are there
only a discrete set of possible numbers
even if they're very very close together
now you could ask the question for
physics are there sort of an
a an infinitely close collection of
numbers that can be implemented in
positions in space for example
but you can just ask mathematically can
there be
just a numbers that are arbitrarily
close together
so in mathematics the idea that there
can be numbers arbitrarily close
together
yep standard modern mathematics says yes
there absolutely can be numbers that are
arbitrarily close together
a so-called continuum of numbers the
so-called real numbers
as opposed to integers the real numbers
can be infinitely close together
now what can you do with numbers that
are infinitely close together well it's
kind of a mess
for example when you write programs for
computers
you always have to make numbers that are
have only a limited number of digits
or they're kind of a little bit like
integers or or
a fixed length of fraction or something
like that computers
only deal with uh sort of discrete
numbers
they don't deal with these they don't
deal directly with these continuous
real numbers you can you can
you can just say i'm going to have a
thing called x
and it's going to represent one of these
real numbers like you can say x
times x equals two so x is the square
root of two number
but it's a more tricky thing to say um
uh whether um uh the
the um uh
to to to characterize that now so here
are some tricky tricky questions in
mathematics so
if you just say let's count the number
of possible
integers number of possible whole
numbers you say well that's infinity
okay well there's a chap called gorg
cantor about a hundred and a bit years
ago
who had this way of classifying
different kinds of infinity he had these
things
he called transfinite numbers and so in
his
in his world the number of
integers is a number called aleph zero
uh it's named after a letter of the
hebrew alphabet
so uh in his way of saying
well there's an infinite number of whole
numbers but we're just going to call
that infinite number of whole numbers l
of zero
okay so then
there's the question of well what about
the real numbers how many real numbers
are there that that
well he said the real number of real
numbers is aleph one
okay so then it's a little bit of tricky
construction
but you can kind of ask the question
i don't think i can i would take me a
few minutes to explain this but
but basically 2 raised to the power of
lf 0
there's a pretty good argument that 2 to
the lf0
should be equal to lf1 that is that if
you
take sort of the number of of integers
and you take that
you say 2 to the power of that infinite
number you get this other infinite
number
that's the um uh that's the um
number of real numbers there's sort of
an argument for why that should be true
okay uh awkward fact in mathematics
uh mathematics as it's normally set up
with the normal rules for mathematics
where we know what we think we mean by
integers and we know what we think we
mean by numbers and so on
those ordinary rules for mathematics
don't tell you if that's true that two
to the l of zero is equal to alice one
it's called the continuum hypothesis and
um
the continuum hypothesis is kind of
interesting because it is a hypothesis
that you can either say it's true or
it's not true
and you get two different kinds of
mathematics depending on which one you
say
and um so uh people often talk about
zfc as a set of axioms for mathematics
that include the continuum hypothesis
but you can also make an
axons of mathematics that don't include
the continuum hypothesis
and those correspond to you get sort of
a different set of mathematical
conclusions
so it's a very tricky thing when you
start thinking about you know
the questions like what are the number
of all possible numbers and things like
this
actually to zoom ahead to something that
um
uh this relates to kind of the the meta
mathematics of sort of all possible
mathematical results
and um in some sense we can think about
the space of all possible mathematical
results
as being a little bit like the space of
all possible positions in the physical
universe
and um we can actually do uh science
on on that space of possible
mathematical results a little bit like
the science that we do about the
physical universe
and one of the bizarre results that
we've just been working on the last week
um is that it looks like the continuum
hypothesis can be thought of as the
analog
of a black hole in meta mathematical
space
not in the physical space of our actual
universe but in this abstract mental
mathematical space
so that's something very bizarre but the
the general notion of a number
it's a it's a complicated notion and um
uh you know when you start really
generalizing it and start
talking about the trans-finite numbers
and things like this it's a complicated
notion i i have a feeling actually that
some of the things we've recently been
doing about the analogies between metal
mathematics and physics might actually
give one
actually a good point might actually
give one a um
a way to think about the most general
conceivable thing
that might be thought of as being like a
number i mean in a sense a number
actually there's an interesting point i
should remember this point because i
about to think about this stuff um a um
this way of condensing you know all
these different sheep
and just saying oh there's seven sheep
that way of of saying
all that matters is the answer for how
many sheep there are
and the details of each sheep don't
matter that i think is probably
bizarrely similar
to um various kinds of foundational
axioms in mathematics
that are what lead one to be able to do
mathematics which
have an analogy to the things that let
one be able to do physics and physical
world but
that's a we're ascending into a
ridiculous level of abstraction which
i'm
i'm hoping to actually understand better
even in the next few days
ah let's see
all right there's some
okay there's a question
oh boy there's all kinds of interesting
questions here
there's a question from kunal why are
all electrons the same
good question we think we know the
answer
um
well
actually they're not all the same they
have
for example they have different momentum
and different energies there's an
electron that can be going much faster
an electron that's going slower
but what we think is that it's kind of
like
when you have a knot in a piece of
string the knot has some particular form
and you can move the string around a bit
but still the knot
the kind of the structure of that knot
can stay the same
the topology of that knot will stay the
same even though you move little pieces
of string around a bit
and i think it's kind of the same thing
going on inside an electron in our
theory of physics
it's kind of like there's this sort of
almost topological this this sort of
thing that's kind of a little bit like a
knot that is
the the core of the electron that is
what makes the thing that you have
be an electron rather than not an
electron but
there's also things like how fast the
electron is going and that's
that's not associated with that sort of
core knot that's more associated with
the actual
way that the knot is kind of laid out in
the universe and so on but
i think the reason that all electrons
are the same
is because it's like saying well you've
got all these pieces of string and
you've knotted them somehow
there are only a limited number of ways
that you can make a knot with a certain
uh certain amount of certain number of
crossings or something like that
and that's kind of the reason that all
electrons are the same it's almost
sort of a mathematical reason uh more
elaborately
well let's say that that's that's a a
good a good first
first cut um my
my friend uh richard feynman physicist
uh he and his thesis advisor a long time
ago in the
1930s and 40 40s actually
was um they were debating this question
about
why are all electrons the same and they
had a really weird idea
their idea was actually there's only one
electron in the whole universe
but that electron goes forward in time
then back in time
then forward in time the back in time
version is a positron the forward in
time version of an electron
that theory turns out not to be true but
it's kind of an amusing theory
of the reasonable electrons are the same
is because there's only one electron it
just keeps zipping back and forth in
time
that theory isn't correct but um uh
but there are different reasons now
okay a couple of questions here uh what
temperature does a laser have
okay tricky question all right so what
is temperature
so temperature when you heat something
up
what's happening what's happening is
that the atoms or molecules in the thing
are going faster and faster the atoms
and molecules have more and more energy
running around
so when you heat something up the the
temperature
is the average energy of each
thing like atom or molecule in the thing
you're heating up
and when that average energy which
determines how fast things are going
gets big enough for example if you have
a solid object
the things will be running around so
quickly that the solid object will turn
into a liquid
or they'll be running around even faster
and it'll turn into a gas
but so what temperature measures
is the average um uh
the average energy of like
atoms molecules in a thing okay
well there's a another little piece of
trickiness
which is in when a thing
is in thermal equilibrium that means its
temperature is no longer changing it
doesn't have
a you know it might be cold at one end
and hot at the other but eventually it
will equalize and all be at the same
temperature
um that's thermal equilibrium when you
get to thermal equilibrium
what happens is that on average
the atoms let's say in the thing will
have a certain energy
but there's a not every atom will have
precisely that energy
instead there will be a distribution of
energies
that um is actually an exponential
distribution
e to the minus energy divided by uh
temperature or e over kt
boltzmann's constant times temperature
and so what that's saying is
that that the chance that you have
an atom with a certain temperature i'm
sorry with a certain energy
rapidly decays so you have more atoms
with with lower
energies fewer atoms with higher
energies
um and i'm i'm leaving out the full
version for people who
who care about this in in um in
classical physics ignoring quantum
mechanics is the thing called the
maxwell boltzmann distribution
and that has a it's of the form if you
look at the velocity of particles in a
gas at least
it's proportional roughly if the
velocity is v it's a v squared times e
to the minus v
squared um is the uh uh is the
distribution
anyway all right so but the main point
is
that things running around molecules
that are running around faster
have uh there's a lower chance to have a
molecule that's running around faster
at a given temperature with normal
positive temperatures
okay okay so what happens in a laser
ah let's see all right the end result of
this story is going to be that lasers
effectively have negative temperature
um the um uh
but let me try and explain that so
in um so what i've said is that
normally the energy of of of atoms
decreases with the probability that you
have an atom of a certain energy
decreases with that energy
um okay how does the laser work
oh this is tricky okay so
first of all what does the word laser
stand for it stands for light
amplification by stimulated emission
of radiation and
the idea of how a laser works actually
was kind of a footnote
to work that albert einstein did uh
on photons um and on the idea of how
photons
work photons of particles of light
originally it was a footnote
by 1960 people have realized who
realized it was more than a footnote and
they invented lasers
but here's the footnote the footnote
was to say that particles that are
so-called bose-einstein particles
um uh uh as an indian physicist
oh what's his first name
uh anyway his last name was bose um
who uh who also invented this idea
um the idea is particles like
like photons uh unlike particles like
electrons
photons really like to be at the same
energy
and be in the same state and if you
have a photon and you
um uh
you have some something like an atom
that is going to emit a photon
um then uh
you um um
uh if you have an atom that's going to
emit a photon
and there's already a photon out there
that is at the same energy as the photon
that atom was going to emit
the chance that the atom emits the
photon will be higher
in other words it's it's more likely
that the atom
will produce a photon if the photon is
going to
uh you know meet a friend with the same
energy so to speak
the exact opposite thing happens with
electrons but the electrons they have a
thing called the exclusion principle
which says if there's already an
electron with that exact same energy
you just can't put another electron
there okay but with photons it's the
other way around
photons like to get together and the
chance that you emit a photon increases
with the number of photons that are
already there
okay so what happens in a laser
is basically that you are you are using
uh the hell this is gonna get tricky
um essentially what you're doing
is you're you're setting things up so
that you are going to have
lots of photons all in the same state
and those ones all in the same state
they all have the same all
the same energy they're all the same
color they're all going in the same
direction
that's how you get this coherent beam of
laser light
but the way you get that is through a
process called pumping
which is um a process where you
basically are inverting
the you're making there be more uh
more atoms that have higher energy than
have lower energy
that's the opposite of what you would
have with positive temperature
you would have it the other way around
um but in a laser
you're effectively trying to have more
atoms with a higher higher energy
and fewer atoms of the lower energy and
then what happens is the atoms of the
higher energy
they all sort of want to emit a photon
and
they're all the photons they want to
emit they're all going to emit the the
same
photons with the same energy going in
the same direction you arrange it that
way
and they all kind of want to they want
to get together to do
even more of that and that's what the
light amplification
by stimulating emission that's what this
process
of um sort of them all wanting to to
throw photons together
um is about um so that's so so
basically one can say that the the um
uh in uh inner laser roughly one can say
that the atoms that are emitting
uh the the photons there are essentially
have a negative temperature
um that's a it's it's not really
temperature in the ordinary sense
because
if you were to just say okay i don't
want to have i'm pumping this with an
electric
field or with electricity in some way to
keep it in this in this weird inverted
state
if i got rid of that that pumping force
it would just go back and it would go
into thermal equilibrium and it would
have positive temperature just like
everything else
but if you keep kind of pumping it into
this inverted state
you can maintain this kind of
effectively negative temperature
and that's kind of how lasers work um
let's see um
i need to uh um
um let me let me um oh gosh a lot of
interesting things
let me try and just do a few more of
these and then i need to go um i
just want to make one kind of comment
for um
i mean this uh i should say two things
first of all
these q a live streams are primarily
intended to be about
general science technology other things
i kind of started doing them because
we're in the middle of a pandemic and i
thought
um kids who weren't in school might find
this kind of stuff interesting
um i think uh it's it's um
so these are kind of i'm i'm trying to
explain things at a sort of uh
uh at a level where i hope kids are
finding it interesting and
are understanding what i'm talking about
um there's also things to say about
our physics project where i can talk at
a
much much much higher level about um
it's like assume you have a phd in
physics then i can tell you this this
and this
um but uh that's sort of a different
branch of what i'm trying to do here
um i do want to say that that um i have
for for years in person um
where i live in massachusetts been doing
sort of every week
before there was a pandemic i was doing
it in person kind of a
a thing with kids which
originally is mostly talking about
programming and making computers do
things
but um particularly as we've gone
pandemic and virtual
has ended up being kind of about
thinking about
things in general and um
uh understanding how the world works and
about science and technology and other
things
and um i'm uh since it's all gone
virtual
i have the potential to uh to have other
kids involved in that and
primarily i would say for i've got two
two groups one is kind of
age-ish 10 to 12-ish another is more
like 13 to 16-ish
um and uh i guess i'm i'm um
if there are kids who fall into those um
categories who are interested i'm uh
um going to be uh sort of opening up my
my zoom sessions at least during this
pandemic time
uh to to other kids and you should get
in touch with us how would you get in
touch with us i don't know how you get
in touch with us i think
i think you uh uh send a
a private message in this uh uh
live stream chat or you send email or
something
um that's terrible i don't really know
but but um
uh um oh okay can email
outreach at wolfram.com um
if people are interested okay i'm just
gonna do a couple more
more um uh
more questions here um
question from anders how do galaxies
retain their shape for billions of years
that is a somewhat good question it is
not as well understood as you might
think
so our galaxy which is a pretty big
galaxy is a spiral galaxy
it's pretty flat a little bit like our
solar system is pretty flat
the planets in our solar system are
roughly all orbiting in one plane
there's not
like pluto which isn't viewed as a
planet these days a little bit out of
the plane of the ecliptic
the plane defined by the orbit of the
earth going around the sun but mostly
planets are in this flat plain
probably because when they formed there
was this big dust cloud
that was sort of spiraling around this
the star that was forming
and they all kind of squashed down
through the force of gravity
into this kind of flat plane and that's
probably also what happens in our galaxy
that it all sort of squashed down all
those hundred billion stars in our
galaxy
kind of squashed down into this more or
less flat plain
of our of our spiral galaxy now there
are other galaxies like the galaxies
that orbit our galaxy
uh galaxies called the magellanic clouds
that are smaller they have maybe
10 million stars in them i think and
those galaxies aren't
flattened out those galaxies are still
kind of spherical
um the now these big galaxies like ours
that are that are spiral galaxies
they're they're flat collections of
stars and they form these spiral arms
they they form arms that sort of
concentrate the galaxies
into this kind of uh spiral shape and
exactly how those spirals are formed and
maintained is difficult to understand
and there are a bunch of theories about
that i think by now
uh well people who've tried to simulate
what happens if you have
100 million a billion stars it's hard to
do
a billion but if you do a bunch of stars
on a computer
you just say all these stars are
moving according to the laws of gravity
they all have this inverse square law of
force between them
just work out where these stars will go
based on starting in a particular way
well people tend to find i think
they now find they can find the
formation of spiral arms
um but uh why those things don't fall
apart and whether you can tell how old
the galaxy is
by how uh uh sort of uh delineated its
spiral arms are
i'm not sure i think there were theories
about that at one point
um there are theories about um well
their theories about
kind of waves of um uh of star formation
and waves of supernovas and things like
this um
uh i don't i don't know that um in in in
total detail i
i i knew the state of that probably 25
or 30 years ago but i think it's
advanced since then
so i i'm not um not able to give you
absolutely the latest information but i
think
i think it's still a bit mysterious why
the shapes get maintained the way that
they do
um
there was a question uh
here um
the uh
um there's a statement here from uh
lefob um it will be really interesting
to observe
the effect of a logic based language on
the cognitive development of children
yeah yeah that's an interesting issue
it's there's this whole question about
whether the language that you use
determines the way you think about
things people have argued about that a
lot for human language
there's a thing usually called the sap
warf hypothesis
that says the language that you use to
describe things
determines how you think about things
and the famous example is
uh you know uh in uh
you know eskimo peoples have a um
have you know many words for snow
whereas um
those of us who don't live in places
where there's lots of snow
um just have the word snow for snow and
you know it's hard to talk about oh it's
a fluffy kind of snow it's a flaky kind
of snow whatever
if you just have one word for snow and
people say that for example
in um uh in some some languages in
antiquity
there was not a different word for green
as for blue
and so there are questions of whether
you know and so that caused people to
have different descriptions of things
i think there is some effect of the
words that you have in a language
determine how you think about things
certainly you know for example if i say
i'm writing a blog
or i'm doing a video conference if i had
you know
both of those things i sort of did long
before there were words for them
um but explaining what i was doing was
quite difficult without a word
so you know having that word it's like a
video conference okay
you know we know what that means um and
um so you know i think that there's a
certain sense in which words help
crystallize concepts um so that we can
explain them
in computational languages the effect is
much greater like in our wolfram
language
um you know we've tried to sort of
condense a bunch of computational ideas
and that uh kind of i would say
dramatically affects the way that people
think about uh think about things
computationally and it's it's kind of
for me it's been very interesting
because as the designer of this language
i mean
human languages like english don't have
designers but
um computational languages do have
designers
and uh the the the way that one designs
the language
affects how people think about things
and that's pretty interesting
so there are artificial languages people
have made uh
probably two particularly notable ones
to me well there's
one historical once notable esperanto
made in the 1880s which was an
artificial language kind of modeled
after
some european languages it's a language
that has a simple grammar
uh you know it's phonetically spelled
it's it's sort of a
simplified language um and you know
maybe a million books have been written
in it i think
um and it's it's it's had some gotten
some distance it was a
i was very sad many years ago when i
when i saw the
european airports they used to have
signs in a bunch of different languages
for the different european languages
and then they'd have a sign in esperanto
and i was kind of sad when the esperanto
signs disappeared i thought that was
kind of the the end of an era
for that but um there have been more
recently there have been languages that
have been made with different purposes
um i would say some of the the languages
that get made for
you know for television shows like you
know game of thrones has its very own
language called dothraki
um and uh uh i'm sorry to say i
can't claim to have watched that show
for more than five minutes but
but um uh i watched it mainly to see the
dothraki language
um the uh uh in any case the
the um um uh there are other or klingon
in star trek is another
artificial language that was made kind
of for for artistic purposes
there are the ones that have been made
for slightly more practical purposes
there are sort of two extreme examples
um which are
kind of interesting one called ithqil
and one called tokipona
so toki pona is a language that wants to
be as minimal as possible and it only
has 150 words
and the idea is that you should be able
to express yourself with only 150 words
i mean in english
we have maybe 30 000 words that we often
use
but can you do it in 150 words not clear
um i haven't really tried speaking
tokipona so i don't really know
but that's one ithquill is the exact
opposite ithquill wants to put
every concept for every human language
in so for example in english we have
you know the present tense i um
i i talk the future i will talk
uh perfect i have talked erised i talked
et cetera et cetera all these different
tenses of verbs
ethquil has sort of a collection of all
tenses of verbs that are found in sort
of more or less all the languages of
earth and i think it has
i don't know 50 tenses or something so
it's attempting to put all of the stuff
one can
into um into this language and so then
the question is
oh first of all i i can i can say that
that um
uh the creator of that language is not a
fluent speaker of the language
um so that's kind of gives you some
sense of
um of the level of sophistication
necessary to have all of these concepts
from all these different languages and
so on
all bundled together in one language and
talking in terms of that language
there there have been people who have
tried to sort of improve themselves
intellectually
by sort of learning to speak that
language as a way to kind of
sort of have more intellectual
horsepower unfortunately
from what i gather the particular people
who've been most involved in that
have many other bizarre problems um and
so that the experiment isn't a very good
one
but i don't know um uh you know if you
taught a kid ithquill
um you know what would happen i don't
know
i think um i i knew one person once
whose first language had been esperanto
um he was a bit award but um i think
that um
i don't know whether that was cause or
effect um
partly because in an environment where
once parents choose to teach one
esperanto as one's first language
um that's a that's an unusual choice
let's say
um
uh there's a question here will it be
possible to tell it from brian will it
be possible
to tell a joke in a symbolic discourse
language
who and what may find it funny that's a
funny question
um i think um hmm
interesting question you know that sort
of relates to what are jokes
and you know we were interested in the
kind of computational creation of humor
like we wanted to have something where
you could ask for from alpha
tell me a joke about a cat and an
elephant
and it would find some you know maybe
it's a pun maybe it's
this maybe it's that you know what is
you know given a
seed can you tell a joke about that
thing
and i think you know there are various
theories um uh
about sort of the role of jokes and and
what um and how
you know how jokes sort of relate to
thinking and so on
um and i i think uh uh
well this question of whether there's a
sort of formulaic way to create
computational humor
i kind of have the suspicion that for
puns you know wordplay type things that
probably is a somewhat formulaic way to
do it
uh which ones will be truly funny
depends on their long tentacles of
meaning stretching out into other
things and really you know that in the
same way that poetry sort of has these
long tentacles of meaning coming out of
words
i suspect you have to have the same type
of thing go on and
you know the next question is could an
ai
find something funny that's a good
question i have to think about that
i mean the answer can it have the same
behavior as we have
upon finding something funny of course
is there some intrinsic notion
of an ai finding something funny that's
an interesting question in other words
what is the
formal computational definition of a
joke just like
we can have a formal computational
definition of meaning
you know can we have a formal
computational definition of a joke we
can probably have a formal computational
definition of a pun
that's pretty easy in fact the minimal
form of puns we experience every day
because when we take the feed
of things that started a spoken language
an
intelligent assistant like syria or
alexa and they get
fed into our world from alpha system the
the first thing that has to happen is
you have to have conversion from the
natural language as spoken
to uh something which can be a written
language which is converted to the
symbolic form
and so regularly something like pi
uh you know pi the mathematical thing pi
equals you know circumference to
diameter of a circle 3.14 et cetera et
cetera et cetera
that's spelt p i but it says it's said
the same in english as
pi p-i-e the um
uh the word for um uh you know a thing
you eat
and actually i do have to tell a story
the the um which is actually relates to
the
uh i think the person who's um uh
managing this live stream today
uh who who uh uh works on events
at our at our company uh a number of
years ago
it was pi day of the century the day
where
in american dates it was 3.14.15
so march 14th 2015 with just like the
digits of pi
3.1415 and we were going to do an event
at a time a big um uh
big trade show in austin texas we're
going to do an event
on pi day and um i
was was like rather offhandedly saying
what should we do for this event
oh we should get a big pie
and um a person who was organizing this
event
was like she said it came back in some
other meeting
um oh you know we've looked for pie
baking places
in austin texas and we really can't find
one that can produce
you know uh that big a pie it's like
what on earth are you talking about i
was you know what i
when i said pie i meant pi
the mathematical thing and i was
imagining that we'd have this big
you know wooden object that was in the
shape of a a
pie symbol not a um
a pie that you could eat as it turned
out at the actual event we had both
just to to to cover bass as well but um
that's a that's a sort of an example of
a pun in action and the kind of thing we
see
oh i don't know 100 000 times a day in
in the kind of things that go from
natural language
to written language to computational
language
um okay i think
um uh i think i probably
should um
oh there's a just a couple of quick ones
here there's a um
uh from chloe uh
saying i once said that long ago richard
feynman gave me a collection of
mathematical tricks for integration
which you didn't use have you published
them and
uh personally saying they'd really like
to see his notes
no i never published them they're
sitting in a file cabinet somewhere and
i am
i am working towards putting on the web
a large collection of archival material
um of which that will definitely be one
and i i kind of feel bad because there's
a bunch of notes that
um dick feinman one day he said to me
here's all these notes about
how to do these various kinds of
calculations you know let me lend them
to you he'd written them in the 1950s i
think this was probably around 1980 or
something that he gave them to me
and i'm like oh sure i'll borrow these
well that borrowing started in 1980 and
i still have them today
so i think i i think i should put them
on the web um i just haven't gotten
around to it
all right well i should wrap up here um
oh actually i'm being pointed out that i
wrote a a post
about dick feynman um that uh has
uh pictures of a few of those pages of
um
uh of notes that he gave me all right
uh well thanks for coming everyone and
um
uh i look forward to continuing this
another time thanks for great questions
see you another time bye